[Musique]
la chambre de métiers et de l'artisanat
de l'essonne accompagne et défend les
entreprises de son territoire
l'idée originale d'artisans d'un jour et
de mettre en situation
une personnalité dans une entreprise
artisanale
découvrons ensemble cet artisan amérique
montchalin député de la 6e
circonscription de l'essonne
notre rôle de député est de vérifier que
les lois que nous votons s'applique
réellement dans le quotidien des
français
et cette journée m'a permis un échange
direct et franc avec sébastien mauriac
artisans compagnons plâtrier qui fait
preuve d'un engagement remarquable au
service d'un savoir faire unique où les
flics regrette mans
quant aux autres métiers le métier de
plâtrier il faut savoir une chose c'est
quand même c'est qu'avec le patron peut
tout faire
on peut aussi bien faire du design on
peut aussi bien faire du modélisme du
magnétisme pas renvoyer derrière de la
façade
parce qu'il faut savoir que tout ce que
vous voyez autour de vos amis à forest
labatut était en pleine on parle
d'écologie
aujourd'hui on est en plein dedans
notamment en ile de france c'est le
bassin c'est là où il y en a le plus de
plâtre en france mais du rêve
oui complètement c'est son père son
naturel c'est 190 degrés pour cuire du 4
ses 809 et pour obtenir le choix est
donc déjà mais en termes de jeu et un
séjour à la nuit tina maze de métiers
plâtriers yves daccord est celui qui
enduit mais c'est aussi
la conception c'est décembre c'est
l'étude c'est savoir se projeter dans
l'espace savoir créer un environnement
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a un savoir
faire rare pourquoi vous et lisez vous
lancer dans la lettre citée gamin
j'adorais dessiner
je n'étais pas du tout dans ce que je
faisais parce que ça me plaisait pas et
on s'est moqué à m'amener
compagnons du devoir pour faire une
visite et puis je suis passé devant un
staffeur qui était en train de dérouler
une statue en train de sculpter tout
machin parce qu'à faire sagement faire
[Musique]
voilà comme ça comme ça c'est très bien
c'est l'autre mad ouais je pense que je
n'ai collègues députés qui seraient ils
sont pas manuel du tout ce serait je
vais leur proposer qu'ils aillent voir
les spectateurs de leur quoi il va y
avoir des moments difficiles et vous
formez des compagnies et des jeunes
compagnons signe chez vous c'est un mois
je fais formateur pendant trois ans
ouais quand j'étais compagnon surtout
aujourd'hui mon souhait ça serait
pouvoir prendre un apprenti tête d'avoir
un jeune compagnon parce que
concrètement aujourd'hui j'ai une grosse
demande sauf que je peux pas reprendre
les chantiers je peux que nous avons
tout ça alors l'objectif en fait il est
clairement de retransmettre le métier si
on forme des gens uniquement
théoriquement bout de métier disparaît
météorique ils sont des métiers certes
quand une partie théorique parce que
quand vous allez faire votre mur il faut
que ça tienne prêt mais il ya là des
mineurs de la main c'est ça par exemple
cerveau quoi et par les tueurs deuxième
beaucoup de métier qui s'apprennent par
l'expérience
le vent on va c'est un combat de
reconnaissance qu'il espère lancer plus
à un artiste artisan car l'entrepreneur
l'artisanant vous avez des gentils
vraiment et des entreprises et mieux
vous avez d'autres qui ont veulent faire
vivre un savoir-faire félicité me
féliciter c'est parce que c'est parce
que ses crochets ressources et du
courage aussi
merci à la députée amélie de montchalin
d'avoir accepté cette rencontre avec
sébastien mauriac dans son atelier à
bientôt pour un nouvel épisode
d'artisans d'un jour
[Musique]